[Musique]
et voilà nous voilà maintenant pour la
deuxième demi finale de ce grand prix
des chèques de bordeaux 2007 7e du nom
après la première demi finale qui a vu
donc l'emporter là outsiders mathieu
cornette le maître international
bordelais le premier maître
international bordelais champion de
france lyon il a éliminé le grand favori
de cette édition de l'iss et florent
précis n'est qu'en fasciné qu'on
retrouvera à 20 heures pour le match
pour la troisième place de ce grand prix
est à 22 heures donc la finale verra
mathieu cornette affronter le vainqueur
de ce match
ce match que nous allons avoir
maintenant alors pour ceux qui arrivent
maintenant je rappelle le principe de ce
grand prix l'échec évident c'est de
faire découvrir le jeu d'échecs vous
pouvez assister évidemment au match sur
cet échiquier géant qui retransmet en
direct l'échiquier où les joueurs vont
s'affronter
on pourra voir aussi le temps alloué aux
deux joueurs donc ce sont des matches en
deux parties de 20 minutes par joueur en
pas plus une fois donc avec lui dans une
fois qu'avec les noirs en cas d'égalité
ce sont des blitz de départage dévisse
de 5 minutes par joueur y aura deux
blitz en cas d'égalité et enfin un blitz
mort subite
avec cinq minutes aux blancs et quatre
minutes au noir nous avons déjà vu un
beat ce mort subite dans les quarts de
finale notamment la victoire d'un des
deux joueurs que nous allons accueillir
ici et bien ce premier ce premier joueur
justement que nous allons arriver ici
qui a fait la grande grande surprise
d'hier
eh bien il a à peine 16 ans il est
champion de france cadet champion
d'europe aussi kdd donc des moins de 16
ans il est maître international déjà
donc ils roulent déjà pour devenir grand
maître international donc c'est un des
grands grands espoirs des échecs
français et internationaux je vous
demande d'applaudir bien fort et à 16
ans pour les encourager parce qu'il doit
être un peu quand même un peu stressé
vous demande d'applaudir fort romain
edouard colin edwards bonjour romain
donc préparé pour ce match
[Musique]
donc la préparation des joueurs
importants il a dû analyser un peu les
parties de son adversaire alors face à
lui un maintenant mais peut-être le
favori de ce tour en tout cas au
classement elo il a plus de deux mille
cinq cents lots il a déjà frôlé même
dépasser les 2000 600 lots a fait partie
des 100 meilleurs joueurs mondiaux il a
beaucoup d'expérience il luxembourgeois
il est grand maître international il
joue en france il a de gagner deux fois
le championnat de paris qui est un des
plus grands open du monde devenant
d'applaudir bien fort le grand maître
international
alberto david alberto david berthaud
préparer voilà fictivement donc
s'attendaient plutôt effectivement c'est
la surprise qui a créé romain edouard
donc le vainqueur de ce match jouera en
finale contre mathieu cornette à 22h ce
soir pour une finale décidément très
très
explosive cette année très inattendu
aussi avec les joueurs outsider qui
arrive en finale donc pour arbitrer ce
match vous demande d'applaudir aussi je
vais vous laisser a pris entre ses mains
le arbitre l' arbitre international de
ce tournoi patrick besse patrie baisse
pour l'applaudir fort merci et je vous
laisse entre ses mains merci stéphane
comme c'est un match en deux parties
nous allons tirer au sort les couleurs
savoir qu'il va commencer avec les
blancs messieurs puis une facette qui se
décide
[Musique]
romain edouard remporté le toss il va
débuter le match avec les pièces
blanches demande aux spectateurs d'être
certain monsieur pendant les parties ne
veut pas discuter
moi même je suis choqué entendez vous
levez la main
donc c'est bon c'est parti pour les
commentaires donc nous sommes ici avec
renault l'a initié en cabine renault
défense sicilienne président donc de
l'échiquier bordelais qui commenta mieux
ce match donc défense sicilienne entre
romain edouard et alberto da bits donc
que alors j'ai pas suivi si si alberto
qu'elle choisit d'avoir les noirs en
premier je ne peux pas en celui que je
pense que c'est alberto qui a eu le toss
le faisait avant les noirs en premier
donc c'est parti donc voyez ça joue
assez vite au début donc il faut
attendre que ça se calme voilà donc
c'est une différence ici laine qui est
caractérisée par le 4 ici des noirs ont
répondu par le pouce et cinq classiques
et ensuite les blancs ou verts au centre
avec le coût des cartes la cécilienne
ouverte donc un échange et voilà on a
une sicilienne un peu classique
voilà c'est une des grandes lignes
principales de la sicilienne n'ai plus
joué la sicilienne année avec les quatre
cavaliers en jeu rapidement le dernier
cavalier de louper donc on développe
d'abord ces pièces aux échecs on vise le
centre
regardez comme les pièces visent le
centre les deux pions ici ce centre
retenu voilà le centre petits centres
retenus en fait on contrôle le centre on
les occupe pas mais on contrôle les
cases des 5es ou cinq ici vous voyez ces
deux là avec les pions on attend un peu
de voir ce qui se passe avant de prendre
des décisions
voilà alors edouard un joueur d'attac
jeune joueur va évidemment lancé très
vite une attaque avec jets 4 h 4 7 ans
elle a joué votre ps3 ici pour à la fois
consolider la case de 4 mais aussi
permettre de jouer voilà la tâche tout
de suite voilà c'est parti
g4 et ensuite on va peut-être même
poussé h 4 h 5
oui tout de suite tout de suite la tacc
évidemment les noirs la taxe sur le roi
qui a donné son adresse son adresse il
est de ce côté on va lui balancer des
pions et chanveaux centre oui quand on
subit une attaque tous les échanges
favorisent en général la défense et
souvent on va dire méchant donc il va
subir une attaque sur les droits sur son
petit rock
il va essayer de résister à cette
attaque
et s'il résiste à cette attaque il
pourra ensuite gagné sa finale avec sa
majorité centrale et la tacle minorité
des pions a et b sur la dame mais il
faut résister la cnac des blancs alors
les pions la marée de pions et
évidemment les noirs ne restent pas
impuissants ils vont aussi faire leurs
attaques sur les ailes dames le proverbe
dit premier parti premier servi
donc le premier qui déclenche la tacc de
pions et qui ouvre les lignes va être le
premier à créer des problèmes sur le roi
ennemi c'est des rocs opposé d'un petit
rock pour les noirs et grand roque
ici on les blancs alors à douter
non donc du président du shit et
bordelais on va re voilà depuis trois
ans de même 36 rue durant le là où le
club donc il y aura le championnat
d'aquitaine aussi deux parties rapides
le même parti qui s'y 20 minutes par
joueur qui ont lieu ou que le vôtre en
six ans durant demain dimanche à partir
de voilà il faut y être avant 9h45 pour
pointer donc entre 9h et 10h - le coeur
parce que le tournoi commencera à 10
heures il ya neuf rondes de 20 minutes
qui est ouvert à tous les joueurs
régionaux et extérieur d'ailleurs
olivier rooney s'est inscrits pour ce
tournoi de parties rapides alors ça
donnera du piment les joueurs qui
viendront y aura neuf joueurs qui auront
l'occasion de jouer qu'entre le grand
maître puisque chaque joueur le grand
maître comme le débutant tous les
joueurs forment le front de neuf parties
pour plus de détails sur cet événement
demain vous avez toutes les informations
sur le programme officiel tout
simplement dans la page consacrée à l'
échiquier bordelais le club qui a
soutenu l'organisation de ce grand prix
des chênes bordeaux depuis deux ans
voilà alors b4 donc ici évidemment la
vie d' attaque le cavalier c3 le
cavalier c3 va être obligé de partir ils
peuvent venir un à quatre ils peuvent
venir à nos deux pour aller en g3 et
pour soutenir la tac
dès lors on va montrer ont montré la
taxe 2 pour ensuite venir
angers troyes afin de soutenir ici les
les pions l eelam salé la taille faut le
roi noir
voilà une possibilité ou alors en a4
pour pour essayer de débloquer voilà
bloqué l'attaqué noir peut soit
augmenter sa propre attaque soit
contrôlée l'attaquent adverse donc c'est
un choix crucial là pour remettre voyez
des possibles c'est pour ça qu'il prend
un peu de temps un peu de temps pour
jouer son cavalier pour là ils jouent à
4 parce que le pion à 5 serait venue le
pion à 6 soit venu en a 5 puis 1 à 4 et
on aurait joué b3 pour être sûr d'ouvrir
les corps au moins une colonne et
peut-être deux sur le contre le roi
blanc devient donc cavalier à 4 va
freiner va freiner la tacc noir
surprenant il a été explosif hier face à
echallens bougies
ça fait toujours de la peine de voir un
joueur éliminé moi je n'arrive pas à
bien sûr parce que ce soir est
d'ailleurs échoué avant de tresser comme
quand tu joues contre un ami aux échecs
l'un des deux va gagner mais on restera
amis gagnent évidemment facile pour mes
edouard cas battu l'irlande hier mais on
est effectivement un peu un peu triste
mais pour le joueur éliminé
et on aurait été autant malheureux s'il
avère s'était produit à l'est on était
content pour celui qui bien sûr voilà
c'est ça c'est ce qui fait la force et
des échecs c'est que l'adversaire n'est
pas qu'adversaire il est aussi
partenaire et ami et il aide à ce que la
partie soit bel de la partie soit bel
d'ailleurs alors ses priorités pas rare
que des joueurs soient contents du parti
perd du week-end quand on a bien joué
que ça lui avec l'adversaire fait de
belles fait de belles démonstrations et
un joli jeu ça fait il ya le plaisir de
l'échec
on le voit d'ailleurs puisque les
joueurs analysent leurs partis l'un sur
et après la partie dans les parties de
manga dans les tournois les joueurs se
retrouvent avec plaisir et autant le
perdant que le vainqueur analyse la
partie sans il partage le même le même
amour du jeu je pense que on est tous
comme ça je cherche un peu la vérité
quoi cherchons la vérité celle de ceux
qui ne sont pas comme ça joue à d'autres
jeux voilà exactement quand j'en profite
aussi là puisqu'on a parlé un peu de
chic et populaire je profite pour saluer
l'équipe qui fait la régie vidéo de
diagonale tv séverine bennama qui
s'occupe aussi de toute la communication
du grand prix vous avez vu sans doute
des articles dans sud ouest
vous avez aussi entendu sans doute de
radio france bleu gironde et tous les
articles ont pu sortir sur le grand prix
et bien c'est séverine bennama qui s'est
occupé de tout ça et qui fait s'occupe
de la régie vidéo sur le balcon là qui
enregistre ce match avec séverine dos
santos aussi qui est venu aussi soutenir
cette production donc tous les matches
sont aussi enregistrées en vidéo ils
seront disponibles sur diagonale tv.com
sur internet le la première émission
télé consacrées au jeu d'échecs dans le
monde
il y en a pas eu d'autres avant
maintenant il y en a d'autres qui
commencent à apparaître mais c'était
c'était la première pendant très
longtemps sur internet
l'émission de télévision consacrées au
jeu d'échecs alors cavaliers cavalières
5 de la part d'alberto david d'encre
action centrale la menace immédiate
évidemment c'est de prendre le pion f3
de gagner un pion mais aussi et si les
blancs jouent le f4 rios postino oui
mais justement je pense que ce cavalier
vise aussi la 4c 6 pour pour un jour
après la poussée à 5 pouvoir aller en b
4 lorsque le pion or avancée ce sera
éventuellement sacrifier pour ce
cavalier deviennent actives sur l'ale
sur les dames donc le vois comme ça oui
moi je le vois comme ça je pense que ce
cavalier sk 6,6 pour les f3 serait
possible non parce que le cavaliere a
pris aurait du mal à sortir le cavalier
enfermé sera quelque peu enfermé après
escale ho / f 4 ans comme cavalier g4
attaque le fou mais se fait sortir par
exemple encouragé via la vallée paris
cavaliers sera attaqué par fou et 2 par
exemple
il a du mal à s'échapper après il est
enfermé donc on n'irait pas là mais donc
on reviendrait sans doute effectivement
je pense que c'est quand même rien alors
j'ai 4 alors qu'elle est l'idée de g45
lui aussi veut il veut retarder la
jouerie des pions bon là il va y avoir
touché un souci je verrais plutôt fou
géants qui dominent le cavalier mais fou
c1 avec l'idée de manger en a c'est une
intrigue est possible aussi parce que si
on joue fougères pas mal on n'a pas de
pièce sur la colonie j'ai alors que
valent pas mal poussé on joue la dame
angers on attaque lucas van gaal sait
qu'après ça soutient la poussée
c'est une autre idée hashcash scène
justice alors peut-être que solide et ce
sera de jouer h5 justement peut-être et
sur la prise en passant jouer cavalier
prince si c'est fou et 6 à 0 10
non je ne sais pas je lis c'est un
honneur c'est ulissi coup j'ai ainsi
toucher 1 pt être h55 pour consolider ce
qu'avait lancé l'idée lecavalier
à noter que regarder le problème de mes
dents qui est très surprenant c'est que
regarder cette case ici de sortie du
cavalier est protégé par le plonger ça
une celle là aussi celle ci aussi plongé
scène contrôle
c'est ici sur la case de cm1 d'inception
f4 qui contrôle dans ce qui a été pris
au piège en quelle que soit l s'est mis
dans le camp ennemi
c'est un coup surprenant cavaillé gk
peut-être un coup vraiment sur trois ans
ou surprenants alors à moins d'une idée
de type f2 fcf 5 aussi est vraiment
montrer cette idée est de protéger comme
ça par f5 sachant qu'on protège avec le
client etc en plus derrière le fou ces
huit aussi une petite protection
supplémentaire et mais la colonne par
transparence en lice tomber le four
étonnant il ajouté trois ans romain
edouard il laisse tomber le foot - ah
oui les îles et se faire car il prend
fou c'est vraiment étonnant la paire de
foule vers tôt david alors ça c'est
décidé on susurre prix sur prix décision
surprenante alors à noter que robert
edwards est entraînée par olivier rené
ironique s'est fait éliminé hier par
donc le finaliste mathieu cornette
oui le fle le fait que le pion soit
bloqué en b 4 et que la case apsys
soient inaccessibles aux fous cette
baisse se fout de cases noires en fait à
une moindre valeur que dans les attaques
traditionnelles contre contre le grand
roque ce qui fait qu'on peut tolérer le
déséquilibre des deux fous contrefout et
cavaliers parce que les pions blancs
vont bientôt ouvrir des brèches sur le
sur le petit recul des âges 6 7 5
ou alors je serai voilà h 5 et 6 où on
voit bien qu'il va y avoir tout arranger
si ce wee ellis et le roi va se
retrouver sous le feu
voilà et puis sous le feu des pièces et
puis foulée 3 et puis on va vous jouer
peut-être le front des 3 l idée de jouer
de5 et des fous prend h7 des fois à des
sacrifices possibles voilà donc c'est
bon on n'en est pas là les noirs pour
l'instant non pas deux voilà dix ans que
temps que blême immédiat mais attention
que la position au centre n'est pas
complètement résolu
la paire de fou n'a pas de valeur alors
très intéressant ce coût 5 alors qu'elle
est l'idée elle est simple d'abord
j'attaque la dame c'est sûr et je
profite du fait que le cavalier angers 4
ici contrôle en 5 sur qui on prend puis
on prend le pion 5d pas prenable et je
prends du cavalier et on prend du
cavalier oui et je laisse le faut voilà
donc et sur un retrait de la dame par
exemple bien les noirs pourront choisir
de prendre le foudroie et ensuite de
prendre en f4 par exemple
est-ce que c'est mieux oui ça a l'air de
quoi m'affaiblir les cases noires bon
quand il a en faveur de ce fou de ce
vous êtes quoi qu'il en soit il et il y
joue la vaccine naturelle au centre pour
essayer de dynamiser ses pièces en
particulier le fou c'est 8 qui avait pas
beaucoup le jeu et puis le davantage
aussi de prendre en f4 pour les noirs
effectivement c'est de pouvoir jouer
foule 6 puisque le fou ne risquera pas
de se faire chasser par f5 du rap union
oui et celui ont échangé le pion et puis
le fait qu'ils aient le tempo sur la
dame
il récupère la case de 5 pour le
cavalier case un chasseur bhl donc quasi
stable c'est vrai ou sur le cavalier
pour remettre le cavalier peut-être
voilà sur sur un coup les dames on peut
prendre un f4 puis jouer cavalier ou
cinq noms parce que l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir un cavalier puissant au centre
qui compensa la paire de fou quand le
centaine cavaliers bien ce tableau sur
l'encours comprends vous prend cariou
cinq foyers il faut prendre
donc si le fou si les blancs peuvent
prendre un seul pour pourquoi laisser
prendre il pas prendre directement le
coup c'est délicat
oui mais là il donnera 5 4 litres en
voilà il donnerait une paire de fou dans
un centre ouvert c'est-à-dire sans
clients fixes et s'embellit de vienne où
il a laissé déjà le fou il l'a laissée
emprise donc le laisser en prix c'est
qu'il avait de bonnes raisons
je sais pas mais moment où il l'a laissé
en entreprises le centre n'était pas
ouvert alors voilà donc cavalier maillot
5 1 l'as lecavalier cas l'idéal
le cavalier idéal qui bloque qui
bloquent un pion libre et puis qu'est
défendu lui-même temps un pion et qui
était chassables par un pion des colonne
latérale donc le cavalier parfait alors
par contre les blancs pourraient
envisager maintenant de recycler leurs
cavaliers à 4,6 porte cavaliers b6
protégé par la dame est le fruit
de manière à récupérer la case des cinq
way pour revenir ensuite sur la classe d
sign on ne choisit pas ça mais bon ce
cavalier est là pour bloquer les pions
pour bloquer les progressions
qu'a donc voilà donc finances tu vois
donc on revient et en fait c'est blanc
qui veulent échanger leurs fous contre
le cavalier oui mais pas en gagnant qui
ont là il menace de gagner sur mêlé les
noms des ces sept les noirs doivent ne
pas perdre le pion messieurs dames c'est
cette protégeant le pion ici qu'est-ce
qui est qu'est ce qu'il va trouver de
mieux au royaume de dieu je pense que ça
va faire voir parce qu'il faut jouer
d'autres cesser les grands joueurs se
surprennent à toujours oui alors par un
voilà voilà déjà voilà il attaque la
tour nous on ne voyait que la réponse
immédiate et il ya le coup intermédiaire
d'abord ils attaquent la tour dont il
peut toujours jouer après un voyage
jours d'un jeune homme 16e suite bien
sûr mais il a intercalé le développement
du fou c'est mieux parce que surnomment
ses sept les blancs refuge où il fout
d'eux en développant leur fou et
empêchant prières et chants ou en
retardant foulée que attarde en tout cas
moi donc là il le suit donc ils menacent
tout simplement fou quand tour voilà
alberto d'avis et laissez-le des
principes aux échecs sait surprendre
l'adversaire mais ne pas être surpris
c'est bien de surprendre et c'est bien
de ne pas être surpris soi même c'est à
dire le coup le adversaires on doit
toujours l'attendre
on doit pas être surpris même quand
l'adversaire joue quelque chose maths on
doit l'avoir vu et d'ailleurs on a
abandonné avant coup inattendu à tour
siens alors peut-être l'idée c'est
simple surnomment ses sets je suis en
train de réfléchir
renoncer de jouer ces trois mais il
pouvait pas jouer tourer pour la bonne
raison qu'ils avaient cavaliers f3
fourchette donc la tour n'avait pas de
belles cases mladic est donc c'est pour
ça qu'il a joué tour c'est alors quand
on est obligé de subir un coup comme ça
parce que c'est pas le coup qui voulait
jouer au départ tour c'est clair que si
on demandait de choisir un coup il ne
mettait pas la tour sur la sur la
colonne fermé derrière le pion dans look
donc alberto d'avis d'ici a tenu compte
de la position particulière des pièces
il n'a pas joué le coup naturel et il
s'est servi de la tour d 1 en jouant fou
g4 et en forçant la tour être passive
n'est pas si facile que ça relou parce
que surnomment ses sept ya le coup ces
trois ans non qu'est-ce qui se passe si
les noirs prennent on reprendre la tour
on voit la dame parce qu'il faut que je
continue à contrôler la case ou 5
elle pourra pas ou alors faudra qu'il
vienne à ses mails adam peuvent venir à
cinq là pour défendre sa faut venir à 5
tout de suite peut-être dans la salle
ensuite oui pour défendre mais en a cinq
quel est le principe c'est passif
l'émotion damas 5
c'est un cookie anti naturel parce qu'il
faudrait essayer de sortir ce cavalier à
vous les changéens pour libérer le pion
à le pion à six qui deviennent un
perturbateur qui joue à 5 à 4 dans ces
blocs le pion à 6 voyez pas un peu pas
le pousser mes poules mais pas les deux
pions à 6 et attaquer aussi la haine par
le fouet oui mais parce qu'on a intérêt
à ouvrir les lignes comme ça parce
qu'après tour à 8 évidemment ça laisse
une colonne d'attac
oui contre le roi blanc oui ça serait
quand même
damas cinq à davantage de défendre les
deux pions attaques et alors mais damas
et qu'on protège à 6
et on n'était peut-être pas essentiel
mais surtout surtout en motoneige le
cavaly à 5 latéralement le cavalier
latéral web voilà latéralement plutôt
que le coup plutôt que le coup
d'am-dam c'est ça c'est ça puisque dame
ses sept dix ans vis-à-vis des amis
fâchés les rayons x 7 x qui menacent
donc gardons ces attaques
la dame avec la tour d'où l'intérêt de
tours c'est un peut-être qu'il est blanc
on peut jouer sur la colonne s'est aussi
dit mais bon tu as et lorsque lorsqu'on
a joué ses trois et qui a eu des princes
et rois le roi blanc a plus beaucoup
d'abris là les deux diagonales sont
ouvertes
la dame elle va bouger mais là les
faiblesses vont rester un risque la
pièce attaqué bon maintenant les blesse
reste en attendant la menace ah voilà
voilà
j'essaie donc qui joue le coup il
s'occupe pas du pian e-menaces tout de
suite de casser la structure chez les
blancs et la structure défensive du roi
ferrand pions
là je pense oui mais péremption après
faut prendre cavaliers ont peu ce serait
un pion au millième pion un pion qui
vaut pas grand chose parce que ils
resteront voilà il reste le pion isolé
eux quatre ils resteraient depuis un
doublé à lui de piora doublé temps là il
sort le cavalier élèves en bep 2 voilà
oui parce que c'est pas possible et
c'est permettre à 4 mais maintenant on
va pouvoir jouer à 5 à 4 j'aurais cassé
ici la structure durable en est le pion
à 4 est quasiment indéfendable donc ça
aurait été un point en pions de plus
bien bien piteux voyez cavaliers v2 donc
arrivés de l'est alors bon c'est une
cavale et qui pourra se recycler un plus
tard par ces quatre oui il a une très
belle classé quatre étoiles et noir
prennent en c4 après le fouet fin pour y
reprendre l'école belles cases pour le
fou aussi oui de la sape sur le renoir
oui ça c'est bien là il ya de bonnes
perspectives pour les blancs
aulas le plan des noirs qui doit être
absolument de jouer à 5 à 4 alors qui
mieux là
et pour ouvrir la colonnade qui a une
meilleure position c'est très difficile
à juger si le fameux puis en d6 arriérés
de la sicilienne qui est faible ou fort
en s'est pas plaint qui est un fauve
puis on faible bon il est isolé mais le
pion à 4 lui aussi est isolé ses
faiblesses contre faiblesse il ya une
belle case 5 pour le cavalier et si on
prend évidemment concède la paire de fou
dans un centre ouvert et on dit que de
foot roy + 3 et galles cette de fou
valeur en fait disent plus que leur
valeur réelle de foot seul m3 + 3 j'ai
cru que franck avait gagné une pièce
puisqu'après puis on prend je me suis
dit dame prend food homme prend dames et
tout prendre mais non il ne l'est plus
allier plus elle est là et le couple g4
a servi à ça mais pour que ça arrive ça
c'est salut 6 nations mais quelque part
les pièces blanches sans mal placé
attention quelque part attention je
parle de la tour c à je parle je parle
de la coordination générale des pièces
voilà son général le loeuff lecavalier
b2 ben il est défensif mais bon oui bien
sûr il va essayer il va essayer de jouer
les ouvertures de lignes aussi veut
jouer j'ai citées ci soit 6 g6 wells est
ici un peu d'air plus h6 parce
qu'effectivement surgissent
oui c'est toujours très embêtant
renoncer le kung fu et 6 ou f6 qui avec
lada et qui en contre derrière attaque
il faut pas se précipiter à donner à
tout de suite mais donc vous soyez
francs attention que les trois attaques
la dame quelle idée de ce prix et
l'océan g5 et après ils espèrent
défendre avec son pion de plus et qu'est
ce qui se passe sur dame 3 qui est l'art
de le coup logique
j'attaque le cavalier et en même temps
je défends le psg 5 salaire alors de
tenir
oui je défends g5 voilà je le fais par
femme soit là quelle était l'idée voilà
quelle était l'idée qui est remis à
temps tout ce qui se passe sur foot est
roi où sur cavaliers detroit mais aussi
ce qui se passe à 3 par exemple pour
intercepter l'action de la dame ou voir
même cavaliers detroit et le problème
reste entier sur le cavalier
même si même si c'est évident que cette
dame proche du roi comme ça ça fait un
peu peur
renault oui tout à fait
tout à fait ça fait un peu peur
peut-être même que romain edouard calcul
les changer d'âme tout simplement
mais non parce que sa description g5
attaqué par le foot c'est le lycée le
problème c'est le problème s'il échange
les dames c'est bon il perd le pion on
perd le pian g il reste avec plus de
faiblesse que son adversaire puisque une
fois le plan j'ai disparu il a le pied
en 4 et le pion h5 qui restait des
faiblesses et ça m'était 3 semble
logique où d'étranges développe une
pièce jeux chaîne percept l'action c'est
de cette dame
évidemment faudrait pas que les noirs
puisse jouer tôt ou tard le couffo f6 de
ce que l'or dans ce cas là il y aurait
quasiment matt d'améliorer matin
l'arrière impossible apparaît voirie
mais pour l'instant tant que l'option g5
et là ça va et puis surtout l'ouverture
de la colonne naquit alors justement
justement rhône on regarde pas si fou
détroit tout simplement h6 oui et le
plonger scène va tomber pourquoi parce
que si les blancs prennent évidemment
souhaité 6 et pouf pouf pouf pouf une
belle et ses matons peut pas parler de
diagonale si on enlève lecavalier n'est
pas le défendre et on enlève le câble et
seimat ici voilà sauf si on le joue sur
la case c'est moins la dame est protégé
banque avait parlé alors qu'à si le cas
ici là le cavalier la voyez défendre et
alain sur cette case c'est zéro balle
après un là ici à l'appui à la rangée
derrière on maîtrise cavaliers sur cette
case c zéro et contrôlerait la case 1 et
la classe b de l'est la classe b 2
d'entre peinard donc l'échiquier trop
petit il faut ajouter une quête
supplémentaire en ses moyens
il faudrait rajouter une occasion le
cavalier puisse défendre un 6-0 16-0
faut être précis il faut être précis
c'est zéro la fameuse case c'est zéro on
en avait parlé si fort qu'on en parle et
7,4 oui oui il faut peut-être inventé la
casse c'est zéro en plus oui moi je
connaissais le coup de l'année quand on
jouait le cavalier sur la case ih un oui
aussi bon quasi si la wii cette case là
on ne voit pas mais alors ici le premier
qui va réaliser les ouvertures contre le
roi de perse sera pas loin de la vérité
qu'est ce que c'est que ce label il
essaie de jouer le plus possible
d'ouvrir à ouvrir les mains j'ai eu peur
de tout et 6 oui sur la prise du pion
réveillère tous ces quatre échecs et
puis prise du pion du pian h et menacent
tout reproche cette map par exemple donc
c'est quoi l'idée et si le pion à je
prends mais j'ai le jeu le pion à
lui-même prend et en suisse bien fou ces
quatre échecs et c'est très grave
1 oui d'accord mais c'est ça l'idée
c'est l'idée du v6 d'accord publicis et
les cases blanches et en attaque les
cats blanche c'est un classique
cependant dans ce type de structure
le fameux full attack le fameux fouet
fin ont débloqué le full attack attaque
les deux cases blanches du petit rock on
va voir pour ça qu'on appelle le full
attack h 30 et 6 h 30 et sur pions prend
oui il y aurait pas ce cas là le fameux
food attaque
ces quatre échecs au roi et regardez
regardez maintenant que la tour les que
les pions se sont échangés ici pour
donner la qualité la tour empêche le roi
de venir se défendre
ici donc et le roi est quasiment maths
et c'est grey donné la tour et c'est
grave pour parer les chèques mais garder
la petite manip de romain edouard garder
comme ces puissants de garder
l'initiative plutôt que de se défendre
il faut parfois attaquer et on sait
c'est une belle démonstration la de la
force d'un fou
qui sur sa case de départ est une pièce
développer en l'oublient trop sur sa
case de départ
le fou intervient il est tout de suite à
l'attaqué n'importe où sur l'échiquier
en particulier sur la case ici sur la
case c4 cette case la case c4 même s'ils
auront sur le cul racisme et non pas
perdre deux pions de temps à perdre ce
puis on va prendre ce qu'ils ont aussi
sévi dans ses plus importantes dans les
weppes à ce que les noirs eux mêmes ont
commencé à mettre en place une petite
attaque qui peut s'avérer pénible mais
j'étais impressionné a autrefois quand
j'étais plus jeune je regardais deux
parties de fisher par le fou de deux
cases blanches de fisher dans l'east end
yen qui reste et ans et 8 oui et qui
intervenait pour améliorer et faire la
tacc de maths de l'autre côté où il
était développé en c 8 mai sans avoir
bougé c'est bien sûr c'est la force du
fou par rapport aux cavaliers qui lui
doit sortir le sort de sa petite écurie
alors à noter quand même que le coût des
noirs fou f6 forcerait les blancs à
échanger les dames parce que la menace
serait d'un grand cavalier maths et donc
on l'a dit ce cavalier n'a pas de
possibilité de sortir sans permettre d'
homme à un matt donc fou et 6 menace
maths et force les changes la voilà donc
alberto david résout les problèmes les
cases blanches et élan élimine le mal
fait
il a compris il a compris après g6 qu'il
y avait un problème sur les cases
blanches dont kiel il élimine ce fou et
fin mardi voilà on est comme ces
logiques des grands maîtres quand même
il élimine le fou puissant de cases
blanches maintenant que les pions ici
awards et font pression sur place
blanche très important la couleur des
cases sur lesquels on attaque la tacc
ici et sur case blanche
donc on élimine ayant un très bon
bouquin de l'avant de manson le dessus
le jeu des couleurs ce s'appelle eh oui
montre les attaques sur les couleurs
avec la force de cette pièce magique
qu'est le fou c'est fondamental qui
travaille que sur sa couleur alors et
quand il n'a pas d'opposants ça pèse sur
france cette échelle alors est-ce que
et noir vont prendre depuis on sait tout
jouer le courage suite c'est les deux
seuls points puis on prend h cet endroit
je suis 3.713 prendre cette europe
c'est pourquoi suite j'ai des
convictions oui tous les pions aspire à
devenir
mais ils peuvent pas ils deviennent des
valeurs de lennon à noter que c'est en
france qu'on appelle la dame mais que
partout ailleurs c'est le premier
ministre ou le vizir et oui le sait sa
tradition voilà à voilà quatre belles
idées et benech belle idée il veut
garder son il veut garder son fou et on
a compris hier que c'est un joueur
d'attac le dénommé romain edouard oui
donc oui là je pense que dans ces
milliers de blitz et de parti qu'il a
fait depuis qu'il est gamin très
intéressante a senti la force du foulkes
blanche quand il attaque un petit rock
il veut pas les changer d'hommes qui le
gardent eux vivent ils le gardent
il veut pas l'échanger contre ce fou
belgharbi 20 préfère dire qu'entre par
contre il va subir le fameux à 5 à 4 qui
va arriver puisque le client devient
libre
voilà si on a 5 4 avec l'idée de prendre
mes trois arrivées que le noir à jouer
roaa suite le fameux parapluie c'est à
dire je me sers tu vas tout va trop
mignon qui va on va d'abord commenté à 5
à 4 tu vas tu va beaucoup trop vite on
va commenter à 5 à 4 maintenant que le
cavalier ici ne contrôle plus la casa 4
et avait l'idée d'ouvrir mais c'est long
quand même c'est long c'est long quand
on voit que ça va vite ouvrir en b3 et
ensuite mettre une tour sur la colonne a
pour venir mater le roi en a un ou en a
deux ces thématiques et alors donc tu
disais tu parlais du roi ensuite je
disais le roi n'a ensuite cessé s'est
placé derrière le pire le pion il
prendra quand il voudra et pour
l'instant ce pion l'aident à partager
sur et sa défense cire que l'on appelle
le pion parapluie et d'avoir le roi
voilà cercle ne peuvent pas faire des
chèques sur deux zones colonies kohler
même si le pion ici n'était pas là mais
non il y aurait pas d'échec de la tour
donc bizarrement exception faite protège
le roi protège le roi mais bon d'un
autre côté c'est sûr que
mon avis n'est allé en finale il le
prendra ce pion et puis il peut y avoir
des fois des sacrifices on g8 est sur
toi et surtout angers cette c1
voilà un peu les rôles sacrifie son gsm
et c'est très important aussi des
sacrifices sur cette case le kw/h is
malheureusement n'existe pas pour les
blancs parce que vous avez soif 6.8 donc
alors c'est une partie d'attaqué très
intéressante oui ouverte et puis les
grands maîtres sans toujours à l'affût
des circonstances particulières de la
position par exemple la le pian 4 devant
la dame un clouage potentiel sur la
colonie qui est ouverte ici sur la triba
sûr que son attaque aboutisse à l'ale
dame peut-être le pion à seraient
condamnés jolie donc joli ce coup là
kelkoo tour h3 entourage 3 pouces le
question cavaliers oui et en plus si le
chaos les bouches eh bien on gagne un
pion gamme prend en grand et tout
reprendre pied on gagne en confiance à
ces moments là sa force échanges
voilà sa force les charges c'est ce
qu'on appelle les échecs réaliste parce
qu'en fait honneur aux rebelles il
voulait pas lui prendre ses trois ils
voulaient pas comme pions noirs se
retrouve en c3 parce que ça ouvrait la
colonne d'eau donc la tap la tour
alberto david a marqué quand même un
petit plus je pense parce que il a
créer plus de faiblesses dans le camp
dans le coeur des blancs
il prend le cavalier et maintenant c'est
la tour ces enquêtes attaqué la partie
va s'accélérer puisque il reste quatre
minutes donc l'essentiel est fait il n'y
a plus d' attaques de match je pense
chez les blancs maintenant il faut
s'accrocher la position pour l'annuler
sinon on va la perdre contre la paire de
fou avec les trois faiblesses le pied en
1 4 le pian h5 le pion à vii et alors on
l'a maintenant on vise le pion des six
oui avec les blancs oui il fallait
sortir la tour au bilan de la tacc du
fou le foie table et là tout est oui
on vise le pion des six oui alors à
noter maintenant effectivement ici le
temps va compter maintenant rien de moi
cinq ans pour edward et trois minutes 50
pour david donc on est passé en dessous
des 5 minutes
alors le pian est attaqué ça devient
critique le pion est attaquée toujours
attention le pion et attaquer bien sûr
donc la menace par exemple cavaliers
prend des six mais le pion à 4,6 on peut
troquer pions qu'entre pions évidemment
les faiblesses qu'entre faiblesse les
nord pour reprendre le cuir ou quatre en
échange du piaui faiblesse contre
faiblesse mais il y aurait cavaliers
prendre sicile et noir prenaient d'abord
le cavalier est bien le fou en reprenant
avec tf c'est le pion et c'est donc ce
serait le pire autour de quotas
peut-être il faut jouer tout reprendre 4
et sur cavaliers prend prendre des six
s'est jouée par cinq pour défendre b5 et
pas perdre un pion un entretien que
leurs cavaliers pro f cette fourche
accueilli price est à huy propos quelle
bêtise
bien sûr ce serait une erreur ah mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup tu es là
e-bay défend et oui ils font pas des six
défunt ça va les prendre et sensible il
veut échanger il faut soulager mais
qu'est ce qui se passe au japon d'ici là
il sera cloué il jouera plan réussisse à
wisques avaler prend f18 je verrai pas
mal bien sûr qu'ils viennent tous qu'est
ce qui se passe bien sûr alors qu'elle
répondait 6 ce que c'est une faute quoi
il retourne et cette mairie il faut pas
oublier cette fourchette à 9 cents hors
17 que c'est que ce coup pour dès cette
année pour 17 sa main oui peut-être 17
justement pour mettre à l'abri mais tour
17 ça marche parce que je fais fou prend
b5 suivi de tour des trois tours détroit
voyez donc apparemment il peut prendre
je sais pas j'ai payé on n'a pas dû
rater quelque chose c'est pas grave à
quatre attaques le fou est sûre pions
prend qu'est ce qui se passe et il le
fait d'ailleurs une prise en passant
c'est bizarre ce qui se passe là
j'arrive pas bien comprendre alors
qu'elle prend à trois attaques le fou
probablement fou prend fou va être jouée
par le berceau david ce qui donnerait la
paire de fou rendrai la paire de tongs
ah oui je sais c'est possible que
rendrait la paire de fou je comprends
pas bien mais évidemment on n'a pas le
temps de tout prix là ça va trop vite il
calcule beaucoup mieux que nous et
vidant les joueurs là ça va trop vite
tout cas c'est la preuve qu'on se fait
pas aidé de l'ordinateur live il ça va
très vite c'est beaucoup mieux
ça va très vite tour j'ai trois attaques
le foot donc c'est moi tac le faux qui
va jouer en abysse je pense sans doute
oui
bref si celle ci s'ils accrochent s'en
fou hehy mais l'action accroche s'en
fout et fx la faiblesse 4 fixe les
supions ne peut plus du tout et voilà il
fixe après celle qu'il ya plus de monde
bien rouillier ce pion voilà maintenant
ici viennent sont régalés du puy 11 7
ouais cavaliers ses quatre lancers
l'égalité matériel mais mes avantages
avantage à torfou contre tours cavaliers
le fou fou fou plus fort que tour
cavaliers
il a pas vu ça c'est sûr bah oui paul
bertho bien sûr cavalli v6 ah oui avec
un père le pion alors récupère le pied
en d5 c'est incroyable de ne pas avoir
pu faire la synthèse
le nombre de coûts intermédiaires qu'on
voit dans ce grand prix le champion
poids surtout dans les parts dans les
positions rapide dans les allées menant
et le jeu rapide
le chanteur pour l'instant ça a été ma
tuque bourne est oui alors qu'elle prend
des cinq à les prendre il a récupéré un
pion tour aux 6 3 6
je vous trouve un rien il faut il faut à
toi marcherait pas il faut 5 f5 bien sûr
mais on joue et on prend tous d'accord
dans lequel on peut jouer tour 1 mais
ces passifs patron du tour c'est passif
on n'a pas trop envie de jouer mais
d'attention il que ce qui se passe là
bas il ya tout reprend 4 simplement
d'accord l'entourent un menace attention
non non non tout reprend le 4 mai à
paris les deux tours non non non ils
menacent cavaliers il faut sortir il
faut sortir la tour mais mais sur calais
c7 est ce que ce pion ne tombe pas il
lâche tout l'alberto qu'est-ce qui se
passe non mais non parce qu'il jouera et
non il peut pas jouer 5 à la fin non
plus
oué mais il prendra la colonne là il
jouera tour arrivent eux qui avait
démâté après peut-être il pourra pas
parce que le sais tu pas maté mais la
tour la tour traîne à la tour ils
réfléchiront medouar la menace évidente
c'est tout reprend cavaliers parce que
sur fion prend évidemment l'atout
reprendre il a travaillé ses recettes
donc avalé ses sept tours c'est 8 ha il
veut enfermer lecavalier 6 cavaliers
dont il prend il prend bien sûr y prend
il va peut-être en faire belle cavalli
les prix de cali il est pris non non
c'est pas précis il a cavaliers avec un
et la polémique où l on voit là la
poigne voilà la poigne toi vu voilà la
pointe
les deux pièces s'en fout rejeter ou
lola à mai contre twente s'échappe à
l'attaquant j'essaie d'aller peut-être
te rend peut-être une nulle du coup fait
il y aura peut-être une nulle comment
nuls et 3 je suis dit j'ai peur foule
donc là je pense qu'il faut prendre
quant à savoir dans mes projets fous ces
trois romans prend en jouant je suis
depuis en menaces ou c3 et mat
donc l'affairé doit ressemblant grande
ficultés il n'a pas vu sa combinaison
huile à la milady dragon 29
la commanderie agent alors sur la menace
pouces et 3 suivi de torah 5 à un match
aura un vrai
est ce que les blancs attention une
minute 4 contre 8,29 y réfléchir la
loire est ce qu'il a trouvé une lettre à
l'agencé abbatiale coup pour donner de
l'air seul coup pour ne pas faire seul
coup pour ne pas perdre il a une pièce
de moins maintenant on remet edwards il
n'a pas du tout vu la lci s'est
embrouillé là dedans oui oui ça il s'est
embrouillé dans la prise du pion à mais
reste une des bombes du 17 août est
possible attention il ya trois pièces
jeunesse de maths quasiment demain on
rase des charges et une tour mais il ya
trois pions pour la pièce il ya trois
ans pour la pièce de maths attention aux
menaces de maths échec
l'échangé de tour en tour bien sûr il
est trop con s'il arrive à lumineux
dernier pion c'est nul oui oui mais mais
le temps 50 secondes contre minutes 6 5
bon finish l' égalité matérielle chèque
fait qu'il ait l'idée qu'elle est l'idée
abobo joli ton retour des huit matches
sur rodez 3-1 non c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal pourquoi matin c'est ce temps le
temps les pirates bien pour aller on en
a 43 les ont formés pourra jouer foule
et bien oui ça va être nul ça va être
nul il pourra jouer faut les deux il
propose nuls n'ont peut-être pas voilà
37 55 il va jouer encore ses chausses
échoué à cause du niveau poser nue la
tension la tension est extrême l'info
regarder dans la tête des joueurs ont
gardé la tête des joueurs pensent que
quasiment le sénégal a tout richesse des
trois temps il faut tous riches et
croise trois fois oui donc prend
maintenant ah oui il faut prend pour des
trois menaces attention la menace du fou
et cheikh où il a vu de la vue parce que
tu y avait foule échec qui ramasse et la
tour derrière
non c'est 5 ohlala et le penser oui oui
c'est bien vu aulas tout retour échec un
superbe superbe super ouhlala attention
ça pousse ça pêche
il faut éliminer ce pion pour les blancs
faut éliminer ce pion est ce que les
blancs une bvm6 quel finish 73.5
différents réseaux c'est un jour leurs
attaques
voyez ils veulent mater les automates
série par un peu peut-être prendre le
seco là il n'a pas il n'a pas fait c'est
cette attention des stations la partie
cette année c'est pro 17
il faut donner oui pour d'autres avaient
pu vous savez ça va être nul ça va être
nul ou et toronto comprend tout reprend
et c'est nul c'est la position nuls à
trois premiers champions roi des six oui
le jour où il prendra un sacré c'est ce
qu'il fera beau nul belles belles nul de
combat
fqu quelle partie extraordinaire belle
et le combat lors la première partie
c'est donc à laval mais quelle partie
extraordinaire
comme vous pouvez le voir ça s'est joué
à montrer de maths et son riz à la wii
alors plus simple activation mais
toujours ces tunnels équilibre les
matériaux que les rois franchise
nous allons donc faire cinq minutes de
pause le temps de laisser des joueurs
[Musique]
oh
nous
[Musique]
oh